In this problem, we are told to define a function called countdown.
Countdown takes one parameter--the number that it countdowns from--
let's call it "n." Don't forget the colon.
The goal here is to countdown from "n" all the way down to blastoff.
This sounds like something that is going to need a while loop.
Let's get started. Let's leave the condition blank for now--
because we already know what we need to do inside the while loop,
and that is, print the number.
We also know at the end, that we want to blastoff.
So we have two things to fill in.
One, how long we countdown for?
Lastly, what do we do after every count?
If we look at the sample, the last time that we count is when n=1.
So, one way to do that is saying while "n" is greater than zero.
Every time we countdown, we subtract 1 from "n"--so let's do that--
and all together, this will produce the outcome as expected.